did you see that jordan peterson clip
about bitcoin money no what was it there
uh jordan peterson was on podcast yeah
can we bring it up why wouldn't they
just buy bitcoin it seems to be to be a
lot simpler than mining it then if it
costs 350 000 to make 350 000 why bother
with the mining you know you said it it
rewards more efficient people
exactly the short answer is if you have
a way of securing electricity at less
than five cents per kilowatt hour then
um you should get into bitcoin mining
business uh which is you know lower than
most rates everywhere in the world so if
you have a source of energy that is
isolated then from the grid or if you
have a cheap way of securing energy then
bitcoin is a great uh weight mining
bitcoin is great but for the most
so does that mean that bitcoin is a very
good way of moving resources from places
that can produce electricity very
cheaply to other places where
electricity is more expensive does that
actually make the electricity the cheap
electricity it makes the cheap
electricity much more valuable
absolutely it's uh this is weird that's
a weird thing
it's it's very weird i think it's going
to have a very profound impact on the
global energy market because for the
first time in history we have a way to
sell energy that is location independent
so a lot of places in the world have a
lot of energy but it's very expensive to
get that to the population center so the
north of canada has so you don't need
wires
exactly jesus that's weird that's a
really strange thing yeah to get
electricity from the north of ontario to
toronto really needs a lot of wires or
you need to you know if it was gas you
need to put it on tankers or on trains
or in pipelines all of that stuff is
pretty expensive but with bitcoin you
just need an internet connection you
take the bitcoin miners to where that
energy is and then you can monetize that
energy and turn it into bitcoin pause it
here pause it here so the first part
that immediately jumps to my mind is
that one they're right right like safety
is explaining that you don't need to
take bitcoin off-site you don't need to
actually move it so you take the
transportation cost down to zero and now
you can actually sell it to the bitcoin
network right there on site which
drastically uh drops the cost of your
electricity which makes you more
profitable and so that's a huge thing we
see this both happening in places like
uh canada but also if you go to
somewhere uh including somewhere like
texas and you see them actually going
right to the wellheads trying to capture
flare gas or you see them doing stuff on
site with these oil and gas companies
like this is going to be a huge business
this is going to be a massive boom to
oil and gas and other types of
electrical producers whether it's hydro
et cetera they're realizing i do not
need to move the energy i can simply
right here monetize it and actually not
only can i monetize it on site which
there's an advantage from a cost
standpoint but also what i'm selling it
for ends up being way more profitable
than anything else i could go do so keep
playing it what else are they saying
here well not only at a global subsidy
but it's so but so interesting because
you could go
to where the energy is cheap with
virtual certainty that you're going to
make more and more money
as the value of the bitcoin increases by
by investing there assuming you assume
that the value of bitcoin is going to
continually increase which is a logical
presupposition if it's if it's as stable
as as is claimed
and
it's finite
in the way that you're describing
and increasingly widely accepted by vast
numbers of people so it's also an
investment that's likely to
increase in value over time rather than
decrease so take some of the uncertainty
out of investing in cheap electricity
generating processes that are
geographically
isolated that's i just can't believe
that's true it's it's amazing that
i i i think i must be misunderstanding
because it seems like you can move the
value of the electricity electricity
magically without any of the problems of
transportation yes exactly
wow that's really something like that
idea that you can monetize energy
production
in in
in areas that wouldn't be able to ship
the electricity to market that's that's
absolutely mind-boggling it'll take me
like five years to think that through
it's so s and it seems to completely
contradict the idea that bitcoin is a
waste of of
of the world's resources right it's it's
it's a complete opposite if that if this
monetization idea is actually true i
mean that is incredible like literally
watching jordan peterson get orange
peeled right in front of you right is he
starting to wake up to the idea of wait
a second not only is bitcoin great from
uh prevention of the debasement of a
currency but also that you can change
the way that we interact with energy we
can convert energy into global digital
store value which is an incredibly
incredibly valuable thing and so what
you're watching right here in terms of
uh what somebody being orange people
this is somebody who's been around right
there's not somebody who uh who's just
hearing about this for the first time uh
i think you're gonna continue to watch
this happen over and over and over again
to people both behind closed doors and
out in uh the public and we're just to
see one by one people are going to wake
up to the fact that bitcoin is good for
business that's true whether you're a
large technology company the publicly
traded markets that's true if you're an
oil and gas business or it's true if
you're an individual that simply wants
to protect your own personal balance
sheet and so that is why bitcoin is
beautiful